[Music]
i want to spend uh the first 20 minutes
talking sort of i guess about the pen
world tables and and related data sets
and the facts of economic growth so kind
of a
big picture overview of some of the
important facts of growth and then for
the second 20 minutes um look at uh the
u.s census data and american community
survey and some work that um i've done
with pete and chang shea and eric hurst
and
and uh john felix brie as a graduate
student at stanford um
on in some sense the misallocation of
talent so if he talked about
misallocation a lot of firms then this
will focus on this allocation uh at the
individual person level um okay but for
the the first part let me talk about the
the facts of economic growth yeah so
facts and then um i use matlab and so i
i made um the matlab code available for
reading the pen world tables or for
reading the census data and i'll spend a
minute or two at the end of each of
these halves talking about
talking about that code a little bit
okay
so uh the first part of this comes from
this handbook of economic growth chapter
that i wrote several years ago
um
here's just sort of you know one way of
looking at uh many countries or regions
in the world gdp per person relative to
the united states so every year we let
the u.s be 100 and ask how rich or poor
are other countries relative to the
united states
and so you can see japan and western
europe there at the top where you know
from you know 1980 to 1985
maybe they fell slightly further behind
maybe that was due to rapid growth in
the united states right but then the
numbers are something like you know 65
or 75 percent of the u.s and then you
know japan obviously was growing really
rapidly but before this period and then
that continued into you know basically
1990 um so you can see japan moving up
to actually 85 percent of the us and
then falling back and by you know the
for the last um three uh you know 15
years or so both japan and western
europe have had income per person that's
roughly 75 percent of the us
so the point i'll come back to um at the
end of this first 20-minute session is
you know well france and in the uk don't
seem to be 75 percent of the us is that
really right and how do we think about
that but you know sort of uh 75 the
number that comes out of the pin world
tables when you look at gdp
um you could see uh brazil there russia
there
china obviously china and india two
countries that uh are very interesting
from a growth standpoint just because
they've exhibited such rapid growth
recently right so you can see china
starts in 1980 in about seven percent of
the us and ends up uh in 2017 i think
for this graph at about 25 percent of
the us
um so remember china has four times as
many people as as the united states and
it has one quarter the gdp per person so
total gdp aggregate gdp in china in the
us
in purchasing power parity adjusted so
using the same prices to compare them
they're about the same size right now uh
but on a per capita basis china's one
quarter of the us
but going from you know seven to 25
over the course of you know this 40-year
period you know that's what you know
seven percent growth per year does for
you right so that's what seven percent
growth per year looks like uh
there uh india starts out further behind
it's some number like three and uh from
you know some of pete and chang's work
for example you remember that you know
there were big reforms in the early
1990s and continuing and so you can see
india
kind of lagging china a little bit maybe
by you know 10 or 15 years but you know
now um in 2017 here reaching about uh 11
or 12 percent of the us
and then finally sub-saharan africa
you see kind of a different pattern here
which is in 1980 sub-saharan africa as a
region had about 10 or 11 of the gdp per
person in the united states um
that they fell further and further
behind so in 2000 this number was more
like four percent right so this is
another way of saying the united states
grew faster in gdp per person than
sub-saharan africa as an as an entity
but that switched after 2000 you could
see they went back up to seven or eight
percent so this is one way of seeing the
broad growth patterns
across a range of countries
um here's another graph that i'm showing
you that shows similar data just just
differently when the horizontal axis is
gdp per person on the vertica in 1960 on
the vertical axis is gdp per person in
right and so um
you could see a bunch of interesting
things in this graph
maybe one big picture point let me make
now because i'll come back to this a
little bit later as well imagine i
hadn't labeled the country so you just
saw the blue circles
the graph would be much less informative
so whenever you have a scatter plot like
this you should label as many circles as
possible and i have some matlab code
that i've given you
plot name sim2 uh
that that will do this automatically for
you um you know with overlapping labels
it's not good so when i'm you know we're
publishing a paper i'll go in and clean
out cut out some of the labels that are
overlapping so i've got a routine that
does a little bit of selecting where to
put the label but it's it's not great um
so
label your data i care a lot about the
quality of the figures you want to
communicate as clearly as possible and
that'll hopefully come through in uh in
my presentation so what else can you see
here um so everything's relative to the
united states being one uh in both of
these periods you see switzerland and
luxembourg are kind of richer than the
united states ireland you know uh famous
for uh the way profits are are
repatriated into ireland to avoid uh to
avoid taxes singapore is very rich as
well norway as well um if you look at
the you know the poorest countries of
the world in 1960 versus today
interestingly look at the scale of the
axis it cuts off at 1 64th of the u.s in
1960 and it cuts off at one 128th of the
u.s in in 2017 and that's sort of
another way of saying an interesting
point which is the gaps between the
richest and poorest countries
uh have gotten bigger over time not
smaller but that counts by country
instead of by person it turns out those
those give you
uh
different views of of the way world
inequalities change so i'll come back to
that point in a second
um obviously countries that are high
above the the line here um this is a 45
degree line that i've got in blue if
you're high above the line you you've
grown um you know you you've increased
you've grown faster in the united states
you've increased in in this in this
graph in the position and if you're
below the 45 degree line you've grown
more slowly than the united states so
you've fallen uh behind the united
states and you can see there are a bunch
of countries in both of those groups so
two percent growth of gdp per person in
the united states which you might think
of is something like you know
what should be possible to everyone uh
even at the frontier
um yeah a bunch of countries fall short
of that a bunch of countries that have
done better than that
um okay hold on one second i'm going to
change what i want to do here i'm not
sure i could totally see if you raise
your hand so if you have a question um
raise your hand i think i'll notice now
i think i just moved something around so
i can see uh
okay here here's another really cool
fact that um
uh
alex bick david lagakos and uh nicole
schindler have and timo beaupart and
pear crusade have all made a big deal
out of in some recent papers and that is
as countries get rich
eventually their average hours work
starts to decline
okay and so you could just see this in
many many countries and they have data
they uh uh the
legacy of shenzhen paper emphasizes
micro data bobber and crusade used more
sort of uh
existing um
summary data across countries but going
back really far in time so this is a
very robust fact you can see it's not
always in every issue so south korea
when it first started growing rapidly
workers in south korea started working
harder
but even in south korea where they were
working more than 2 800 hours per worker
um by the end of the 1980s it's
plummeted a lot so down to you know 2200
or even less
but you see the same pattern in japan
and france and the uk and even in the us
the us is one of the smallest declines i
would say in hours work but you know
you the the 2 000 hours per worker in
1950 now looks more like 1800 hours per
worker uh today in the united states so
um you know thinking about what what's
behind these broad patterns i would say
uh and this is a hit you can see in a
lot of my papers probably half my
research papers
are have the following character
identify a key fact in the data
that no one's going to argue with like
this fact you know we're not going to
argue with it it's true it's robust and
then ask can you write down a model
where that happens
and does that model have extra
implications that that might be
interesting you know can you can you
make it happen not just qualitatively
but quantitatively and you know what
explains why people in south korea work
work so much harder than people people
in japan and what explains the upward
trend and then the downward trend you
know looking at trends and try to
explain them is a you know half my half
my papers are kind of of that character
i think so that's a way i like to to do
research some infatuated with with
graphs like this on site
okay um i mentioned before that you know
when you look at the country level it
looks like the rich countries are are
even richer than the poor countries the
gaps have kind of widened so so global
inequalities increased if you look at
the country level but it's certainly not
true at the individual level and that's
a really really important point this
graph i would say you know because
growth economists don't typically look
at the individual level we don't
emphasize it as much as we should but
it's probably you know like the first
graph you should show in any class on
economic growth in some sense so so what
is this graph so horizontal axis is gdp
per person um
relative to the us being won in 2017. so
i'm going to show you data for 1960 and
2017 but the us is equal to one only in
2017. okay so the us would be
um
i don't know a factor of three poor us
would be 0.33
uh
is that right uh
uh yeah i think that would be right you
should be 0.33 in in in 1960 so that's
where the us is right up here
good okay so so what do you see what
i've done here is i've assigned each
person in every country
their own gdp per person so you can see
china and india are these big jumps and
the vertical axis sorry should have says
already this is what fraction of the
world's population
lives in countries with gdp per person
less than whatever the number is on the
horizontal axis
okay
and so you know i i've written the
summary here to to help remind me what
to say in 1960
two out of three people in the world
lived in countries with gdp per person
less than five percent of today's u.s
level so less than about seven dollars
per day so if we go to where the
two-thirds point is you know right in
here
right you'll see um that's at about
one-twelfth of of of the u.s uh you know
in income i think uh
sorry um
five percent i want to be one twentieth
right so uh down down here probably i'm
not good at drawing my lines across all
right so two two out of three people in
the world in 1960 were were very very
poor
what fraction of the world's population
today lives at that same level seven
dollars per day or less than five
percent of today's 2017 level the answer
is only one out of 12.
right and so what the point that was
here
is now way down here and you can see you
know a big part of that is china and
india with you know kind of
you know two and a half three billion
people in in the world um you know as
china and india grow rapidly that's
lifted two and a half or three billion
people
out of this extreme poverty and you know
that's an incredibly impressive
achievement right so at the individual
level there's been a decline in global
inequality even if at the country level
there hasn't you know there's been an
increase but i think the individual
level is kind of in in for this question
what we care about so as i mentioned
this treats each person within a country
as having the same income which is
obviously not true um you could do
better and various people if try
have tried to bring this to the data as
well using something like the world
wealth and income inequality database um
uh chavez sally martin uh martin revlon
um various other people have sort of
added within country inequality to this
graph and it just reinforces the point
basically so the changes in within
country inequality are small relative to
these these big gains in income per
person that we see in places like china
and india
um
okay
now i want to shift gears to um a paper
with pete um i think this you know
these first two hours are you know all
about pete's papers i think is one way
to look at it um this is a paper where
we did the following go back to that
france example where i said you know
france turns out to have about 70 of the
gdp per person in the united states and
if you look at consumption per person it
would be about 65
people in france are surprisingly poor
when you just look at their consumption
um and you know when i go to france
france seems like it's a
pretty successful country and has some
some things to like about it so so is
there something wrong with the gdp
numbers is kind of partly the motivation
for this
and when you look at the data one thing
you appreciate is that sure france has
low consumption
but france has high life expectancy
people in france live about two years
longer than people in the united states
they don't work that hard but that means
they have a lot of leisure right so
people in france have more leisure than
the united states and inequality is
lower so behind the veil of ignorance
you're going to be born as a random
person in the united states and or
france
where would you rather be born as a
random person well the inequality piece
of it if i said you're going to be a
poor person you'd rather be a poor
person in france i think and so that the
inequality um is going to be bigger in
the united states and behind the veil of
ignorance we'd like some insurance
against that so that's going to that's
in some sense a reduction for the u.s as
well so what we do in this paper is we
write down a standard utility function
the kind that economists use to study
you know asset pricing or exchange rates
or international trade or business
cycles or everything else labor supply
write down a standard utility function
that also includes years of life so you
add up over your years of life your u of
c comma l
and your consumption is uncertain your
your leisure might be uncertain as well
and so you know we take that inequality
into account we ask you know what's the
consumption equivalent welfare put
everything in consumption units um how
much would you have to um
give up take take take away from
um a french person to have them suffer
the low life expectancy in the united
states and be indifferent there so
that's the kind of question we're asking
and what you can see in this chart
on the horizontal axis is gdp person us
equal one on the vertical axis is the
welfare number i realize i'm going too
slowly right they need to speed up
um
and they're highly correlated so the
correlation is 0.95 so the first thing
is sure all these other things matter
but gdp per person is a good summary
statistic there's a reason why we use it
but
that's not the entirety of the story if
you look closely you can see a bunch of
rich countries are above the line
and the poor countries are
disproportionately below the line and so
the gaps are large so on the vertical
axis now the horizontal axis is the same
on the vertical axis i have the ratio of
welfare to income so how much higher is
consumption equivalent welfare than the
income comparison would suggest and look
at france for example france is about 30
percent richer
than their income would suggest and so
instead of being 65 or 70 of the us
france is going to look like 90 or 95
percent of the u.s um in these
calculations and you can see uh the uk
sweden
um you know are going to be like that
there are other countries poor countries
the world most of the countries
are below the one and so there are many
countries to get deductions okay so let
me let me show you some of these picking
out some of the countries to show you
what's going on so life expectancy the
the the actual numbers for the variable
life expectancy in the us is about 78
years our consumption gdp ratio is about
hours worked in the us
not per worker but per person is 836 so
this is the the opposite of leisure in
blue but it's the leisure uh adjustment
and then consumption inequality the
standard deviation of log consumption in
the u.s is something like 65-66
okay
so now france gdp per person for in 2007
here was 70 of the us
but as i said people in france live
longer i guess it's three years instead
of two years
um
they have high lower consumption right i
already said that they work less 600
hours rather than 800 hours so that's a
lot less work and a lot lower inequality
standard deviation of log consumption 47
instead of 66
how much is each of those worth well
interestingly the inequality adds 10
lower inequality adds 10 percent higher
leisure only adds six percent you might
think maybe it should add even more
maybe we're being conservative here
right 600 hours versus 836 hours but it
only adds six or seven percent with our
standard preferences longer life
expectancy each year of life is worth
about five percent of consumption right
so three years gives you about 16 when
you add all those things up france looks
like you know ninety percent of the us
rather than seventy percent of the us um
let me go down again in the interest of
time let me pick a very poor country
like um botswana which
doesn't look poor when you look at their
gdp 25 percent of the us was one of the
richest countries in uh sub-saharan
africa
but
when you look
you know they have lower life expectancy
much lower because of uh aids um in this
period 52 years versus 77 years remember
each year of life is worth about five
percent of consumption so this knocks
off 77 log points
right
they work slightly harder and there's
even more inequality in botswana and
inequality reduces consumption
equivalent welfare by 33
so instead of looking like 25 percent of
the us instead of being pretty
impressive
on a consumption equivalent welfare
basis botswana looks even poorer like
five percent of the us and we find this
in general so western europe looks
closer to the us because you add in
their longer lives and their lower their
higher leisure
um the poorest countries the world look
even poorer when you do things this way
okay
um let's see what i want to do i'm gonna
i love these facts these are my new
papers so uh these are graphs i added
chad i will suggest that you keep going
you take a few extra minutes because we
do have some some margins okay i'll yeah
i
as pete said i i think i get too excited
and put too many things in here okay
right
so so another cool fact about the world
which you you might not appreciate ask
yourself what happens to global
population 100 years from now
does it level off does it keep rolling
well i
if you'd asked me a year and a half ago
i would have said my guess is gonna
level off with like i don't know eight
or nine billion people something like
that it turns out all of the rich
countries in the world
have fertility rates below replacement
okay
what do i mean here
how many kids does each woman have on
average and you know two kids per woman
on an average would be replacement that
would be maintaining a constant
population if you look at the high
income countries as a whole
they have 1.7 kids per woman the us is
1.8 china 1.7 germany 1.6
japan italy spain even less so
you know and as as countries get richer
the fertility rates decline that's the
fact that you probably knew what what i
hadn't quite appreciated you might have
thought well they level off it too
somehow but you know as soon as you see
that you realize well there's nothing
special from an individual family
standpoint about two kids in fact when
we look at india you know they used to
have six kids per woman then five then
four then three and now 2.5 you can see
they're headed for this too
and there's you're not going to stop
necessarily and if we look at all the
other countries in the world that have
gotten rich they haven't stopped they've
gone right below to so i have a paper
that i won't talk anymore about but it's
called the end of economic growth so the
growth models i like population plays a
very important role because people
produce ideas so if if actually the
future of global population is that it's
declining
because we're having fewer than two kids
per one
that might actually lead to well it's
the empty planet that the book that i
took um these facts from uh there's a
book that the title empty planet but it
actually leads to the end of economic
growth as well and so so you have this
stagnation of living standards on a
planet that gradually empties of people
and this is a very different view of
growth from our standard view where we
say you have exponential growth and
living standards for a population that
grows exponentially right that's the
view i had
of growth before i worked on this paper
and now i realize well it's it's it's
not quite so clear
um
uh finally there's some growth
accounting this is a another new thing
that i've done that kind of lays out
where does growth come from um this one
i think i will skip because i'm taking
time from from my next session now so i
mentioned these these programs are
available um there's a collection of
subroutines that i've written called in
chadmatlab.zip
and here the key programs that you need
to read the pin world tables and to make
the graphs that i've made and it shows
you how to to label the countries and
you know here's some some code to help
your your your graphs look nice
[Music]